Haha just kidding, I just wanted to freak
some of you out.
So I’ve been wearing contacts for nearly
ten years now.
And have always wondered, is touching my eye
every day doing something bad to my eyes?
Apparently putting contacts in your eye is
“not a neutral act” according to microbiologist
Maria Gloria Dominguez-Bello.
In fact, contacts might just change more than
your vision.
Dominguez-Bello and other researchers from
NYU’s Langone Medical center found significant
differences in the ecosystems of the eyes
of people who wear contact lenses and those
who don’t.
In their study, they took hundreds of swabs
of people’s eye conjunctiva, which lines
the eyelids and covers the white part of your
eyes, and swabs of the skin directly under
the eye.
They found thousands of different strains
in the different parts of the eye.
But in those people who wore contacts, they
had more bacterial diversity in the skin beneath
their eye and a higher amount of different
kinds of bacteria on the surface of the eye
itself.
They had three times the usual proportion
of certain bacteria like Methylobacterium,
Lactobacillus, Acinetobacter, and Pseudomonas
bacteria in the eyes.
Basically, the bacteria on the surface of
their eyes looked more like the types of bacteria
found on the skin beneath their eye, when
compared to those who don’t wear contacts
at all.
But the researchers still wonder if this altered
bacterial composition is because contact wearers
keep touching their eyes with their dirty
little fingers or if it’s the lens itself
that is changing the immune system of the
eye.
So more research is needed.
However, the researchers think this could
be part of the reason contact wearers get
more frequent eye infections.
Since the 1970s when soft lenses came on the
scene, corneal ulcers have been on the rise.
Corneal ulcers leave a nasty open sore on
the cornea.
They’re caused by bacterial, fungal or viral
infections, mostly Pseudomonas.
Since that type of bacteria is found on the
skin, eyelid and hand hygiene might be to
blame.
Specifically, another study published in Optometry
and Vision Science identified three specific
behaviors that might lead to nasty infections.
And they’re pretty straight foward
like not washing hands with soap and water
before handling contacts, not letting the
case air-dry, surprisingly and i’m a little
skeptical on this point, using a contact case
and a solution from different manufacturers.
I mean some bottles of solution come with
cases, but I just assumed they were being
nice, and all that “please use our solution
for the best results or whatever” was just
marketing BS.
But maybe not?
Or if you’re too lazy to do any of that,
you could try contacts coated with anti-microbial
stuff.
One study also published in the journal Optometry
and Vision Science tested a type of contact
coated with melamine.
This peptide fights microbes by inhibiting
their growth.
In this study, human volunteers wore these
coated contacts for a day with no major side-effects
and they were just as comfortable as regular
lenses.
So that could be handy to have.
And I know I know, it sounds scary that YOU
HAVE BACTERIA IN YOUR EYE.
But bacteria is everywhere in and on us, we’re
like a walking ecosystem.
And not all of it is bad, our microbiome might
be beneficial for health.
But some bacteria do cause nasty infections
if they get out of hand, so if you’re worried
basically, keep your contacts clean?
It shouldn’t take science for you to get
that.
Just get a nice routine down of washing your
hands before you handle your contacts and
air-drying the cases every now and then.
But if shaving is part of your routine, maybe
you should wait to take your contacts out
AFTER you’re done with that.
You might need to see for shaving your face
and stuff.
And if you need a razor that delivers a superior
shave, Try Harry's!
We couldn't have made this episode without
their support.
Harry's was started by a couple guys passionate
about creating a better shaving experience.
They're cheap, they show up at your door,
and they're sharp both in look and… well,
sharpness.
You can support the show AND look sharp by
going to Harrys.com and using the promo code
DNews to save $5 off your first order.
After using this code, you can get an entire
month's worth of shaving for just $10!